herzlich willkommen zur folge 182 das
faz einspruch podcast der wöchentlichen
podcast der faz für recht justiz und
politik heute am 20 oktober
2021 mein name ist corinna budras und
mit dabei ist wieder
piano ransmann aus köln ja liebe ja wir
müssen leider mit einer diesmal für uns
sehr unangenehmen hausmitteilung
starten uns meine ich es in diesem
zusammenhang die faz wir haben wirklich
ganz bezaubernde post von einem hörer
bekommen der verzweifelt versucht seit
zwei wochen ein abo abzuschließen
und sich dann aber netterweise gemeldet
hat nicht etwa auf gegeben hat sondern
sich gemeldet hat und gesagt hat das
funktioniert nicht tut bitte was und
unsere lisa marktabteilung und sonstige
menschen die damit betraut sind haben
sich sofort gemeldet und hier fehler
gefunden
es hat an einer fehlerhaften schufa
abfrage geharkt ich möchte wollte da gar
nicht tiefer rein gehen ehrlich gesagt
ich kann jetzt verkünden dass es geht
ich bedanke mich wie gesagt sehr für
diese beharrlichkeit und sie auch echt
total entzückend wenn menschen sich dann
die mühe machen zu schreiben und nicht
einfach sagen ach komm da kriegt er hat
kein abo wenn ihr dann technik gehabt
das ist wirklich total entzücken dafür
muss man sich für echt bedanken und das
kann ja auch ein schönes vorbild sein
für viele hörerinnen und hörer die sich
immer mal wieder fragen wie sie diesen
podcast der kostenlos im netz ist
eigentlich unterstützen können es geht
ihm wie gesagt ganz einfach über ein faz
einspruch ab das magazin dass ich eben
auch mit juristischen themen beschäftigt
da werde ich die funktionierenden links
in die show nutzt ruhe es geht aber
übrigens auch wir haben ja auch
wahnsinnig viele leute in die nicht jura
studiert haben und als ich auch gar
nicht so mit rechtlichen dingen
ansonsten in ihrem lebens in dieser
lebenswirklichkeit beschäftigen wie
übrigens der hörer der sich hier
gemeldet hatten der für den gibt es
natürlich auch noch andere möglichen
also dieser woche zeit einspruch
abonnieren auch das soll auch menschen
kennen die sich für rechtsthemen einfach
so indiana und sollten das können wir
gar nicht oft genug sagen aber ansonsten
kann man natürlich das ganz normal faz
plus abo oder auch die print zeitung
oder was es gibt
abonnieren also herzlichen dank für das
interesse sag ich jetzt mal ach und
rückmeldungen solcher art oder auch er
hinweise korrekturen bitte immer ein
einspruch podcast faz.de schicken sowie
ist er freundlich höhere getan hat und
es gab übrigens noch einen hinweis da
wurde nach kapitel marken gefragt wie
wir früher auch immerhin drin hatten
also dass man quasi automatisch zwischen
den kapiteln wechseln konnte das ist aus
technischen gründen leider jetzt nicht
mehr ermöglicht deswegen haben wir die
etwas mühselige variante gewählt das
händisch immer ein zu tragen also wir
geben die minuten angaben
und dann kann man auch so zwischen den
themen wechseln aber es geht eben leider
nicht mehr so automatisch wie früher
apropos themen da kommen wir jetzt
endlich mal zu nach dem langen langen
intro
haben wir doch so viel spannendes heute
vorkommen hab ja es gab wirbel um ein
crooner dean
hause doch irgendwie ein crazy world
aber ja es gab wirbel darum ob der
präsident des bundesverfassungsgerichts
befangen ist und ja die haben gesagt sie
seien es nicht wir werden euch erzählen
warum ich muss das übrigens auch noch
mal gerade rücken oder ein crooner
klingt ja so als hätte sich da die
bundesregierung und die justiz also das
bundesverfassungsgericht zu einem
dinner getroffen dass gegen jegliche
chor ohne auflagen verstößt so war es
natürlich nicht sondern die haben sich
im juni getroffen und das hat eben wie
gesagt zu einem befangenheitsantrag
geführt also insofern muss man natürlich
vorsichtig sein mit den bezeichnungen so
also das ist wird unser erstes thema
sein was haben wir dann noch dann haben
wir das bundesarbeitsgericht und das b
ag hat entschieden dass es während eines
corona lockdown es für eine 450 euro
also eine minijobberinnen keinen lohn
gab wäre der laden dicht war weil die
weil aufgrund allgemeinverfügung eben
keiner arbeiten gehen durfte wir
erklären euch später mal warum und warum
das gar nicht mal so klar war dass das
so entschieden werden würde und dann hat
corinna einen super spannenden
schwerpunkt machen ein bisschen ein
anderer dreh zum thema
entkriminalisierung von cannabis tja da
bin ich auch sehr stolz darauf was
schönes gespräch das kann ich hier schon
mal ankündigen wir unterhalten und ich
unterhalte mich mit florian leine
politikstudent aus würzburg der
tatsächlich mal in die fänge der polizei
der staatsanwaltschaft der justiz
gekommen ist wegen geringen mengen von
cannabis und uns mal ein bisschen
erzählt was dann geschah so und alles
weitere wenn wir nach erklären dann
haben wir noch in unserer kategorie was
kommt was ganz skurriles nehmen dass
nämlich das verfahren gegen den drachen
lord und bei einigen mag jetzt hier
schon die alarmglocken
schrillen das ist ein youtuber der wir
sehr auffällig ist der auch viel
aufmerksamkeit auf sich zieht und es
geht eigentlich wirklich um ziemlich
lapidar
vorwürfe aber das führt immerhin dazu
dass ein riesiger raum angemietet werden
muss und auch dazu werden wir später
mehr erzählen aber noch nachtrag und das
gerechte urteile gönner das gerechte
urteil auch da wieder heute relativ bund
es geht um jürgen klopp
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir legen jetzt mal los
nämlich mit dem wirbel um das nicht
corona anfang der woche hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht sich konkret
seinen präsidenten professor stephan
harbarth und die professorin susanne
baer für nicht befangen erklärt obwohl
sich richter des
bundesverfassungsgerichts mit
mitgliedern der bundesregierung
getroffen worden erzählt auch mal ein
bisschen genau worum es geht ja da muss
man natürlich zunächst einmal wissen das
ganze ist natürlich immer hängt an einem
gewissen verfahren denn also wir wissen
ja dass es ja schon etliche klagen
anhängig sind etliche verfahren viele
verfassungsbeschwerden sind anhängig vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht zum thema
corona kommune auflagen deswegen rede
ich hier mal etwas lapidar von corona
dina und einer der anwälte konkret niko
härting der da ein kläger vertritt ein
beschwerdeführer vertritt der hat die
besorgnis der befangenheit und deswegen
einen antrag gestellt um
überprüfen zu lassen inwieweit sich hier
die richter des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
wir beeinflussen lassen von der
bundesregierung also im grunde genommen
sehr delikate vorwurf der jetzt nicht
alle nase lang erhoben wird aber ist
auch nicht das erste mal kann man sagen
aber das ganze ist schon durchaus
hochinteressant deswegen wollen wir sind
ein bisschen vertiefter diskutieren weil
es auch so ein bisschen zeigt er wie
geflogenheiten sind zwischen den
verfassungsorganen so möchte ich mal
formulieren davon nämlich vergessen der
bundesregierung ist ein verfassungsorgan
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht gehört
in diese riege der fünf sehr gewichtigen
verfassungsorgane so und worum ging es
nun konkret es kam am abend des 30 juni
zu einem zusammentreffen zu einem
abendessen zwischen der bundesregierung
und dem bundesverfassungsgericht also
konkret erster senat und zweiter senat
und zwar kann die zusammen im
internationalen konferenzsaal des bundes
und warum hat man sich da jetzt
getroffen ja das ist eine gute frage das
passiert schon regelmäßiger dass man
sich trifft also ein vielleicht zwei mal
im jahr übrigens auch nicht nur mit der
bundesregierung auch der bundestag wird
mal besucht und dann auch also es gibt
wirklich ständig irgendwelche
pressemitteilung des
bundesverfassungsgericht wo die
berichten mit wem die sich alles
treffende delegation aus russland
portugal hier heute gewählt und portugal
aber auch gesagt immer so
machen die eigentlich den ganzen tag
aber es gehört das gehört eben einfach
auch dazu so und nun ist das aber nicht
ganz
unverfänglich so möchte es mal
formulieren also im zuge dieses dieses
abendessen
gab es eine reihe von berichterstattung
also die faz hat auch darüber berichtet
aber eben vor allen dingen auch die welt
und welt am sonntag und so ein paar
details die ich übrigens auch hier aus
einem größeren artikel der in der wams
erschienen ist also in der welt am
sonntag zb
das antipasti rinder geschnetzeltes
schokoladenmousse und eine käseplatte
serviert wurden ja da hier vielleicht
eine kleine ich hatte schon vor dem
wodka stoner vielen dank für diese total
eine wand hin vor
das war aber vermutlich nicht die
informationen die zum befangenheit
problem oder zum möglichen befangenheit
örtlichen für so eine kleine
journalisten marotte dass ich mit dieser
gelegenheit mal extreme machen
journalisten immer gerne um credibility
unter beweis zu stellen wer weiß was auf
dem tisch stand weiß auch was geredet
wurde so ungefähr
teilweise werden dann irgendwie auch
nicht gefühle geweckt arbeitet ist jetzt
bei rindern geschnitten vielleicht nicht
so dass wir die auch noch hinkriegen so
aber das delikate war eben einfach
worüber haben den gesprochen als man
muss sich auch vorstellen das war jetzt
nicht so total kozina also man allein
die 16 richter und dann das
bundeskabinett sind ja auch noch mal
fünf leute und wer weiß wer da alles
noch im raum saß nicht also das ist
schon sehr institutionell ist dass man
sich jetzt glaube ich echt nicht zu
muckelig vorstellen so läuft jetzt auch
nicht genau so und im rahmen dieses
essens wurden verschiedene reden
gehalten und zwar gab es eben das thema
entscheidung unter unsicherheiten ja und
das ist so ein bisschen auch der streit
der knackpunkt an dem sich der streit
entzündet denn
eigentlich war für diesen abend was ganz
anderes geplante man sollte über
cyberattacken und so weiter sprechen das
war alles vielleicht ein bisschen
kriminalistischer ja oder jedenfalls
strafrechtliche wand der und nicht so
verfing nicht wie man jetzt hier diese
entscheidung unter unsicherheiten aber
es war ein offensichtlich ein vorschlag
der insbesondere vom präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsgerichts aus gegen
stefan herbert er sagte lass uns doch
dann die bei darüber reden ja und ja
woran denkt man wenn man hört
entscheidungen unter unsicherheiten in
coruña man also auch schon oder ja ich
glaube das war eines der schlagworte vor
allem des jahres 2020 als immer alle
gesagt haben und es wurde eben dann
sozusagen je mehr kritik es gab ein
chaotischer kuchener politik wurde eben
desto stärker seitens der politik betont
wir müssen uns eben hier unter
unsicherheiten entscheiden und auch die
justiz muss natürlich diese unter
unsicherheit getroffenen entscheidungen
nachher überprüfen während das ist im
prinzip ja das woran diese
befangenheitsanträge von niko härting
der übrigens habe ich die freien wähler
vertritt
aufgehängt wurden dass die gesagt haben
stephan harbarth hat von sich aus um
eine offensichtlich darum gebeten das
thema des abends zu wechseln und dann
eben über entscheidung unter
unsicherheiten zu sprechen genau da
wurde eine rede gehalten von
bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht
unter anderem also das redemanuskript
liegt auch vor ob es zu gehalten wurde
oder ob es abweichungen gab das weiß man
nicht so genau aber jedenfalls nach dem
redemanuskript tauchen da ebenso
formulierung auf wie das die regierung
mit einem erkenntnis vakuum konfrontiert
war und das natürlich trotzdem die
notwendigkeit bestand der korona
pandemie entschlossen entgegenzutreten
uns hätte das natürlich gravierende
folgen gehabt und dann soll sie auch
noch gesagt haben laut redemanuskript
die verfassungsrecht gesprächen erfülle
ein kontroll und keinen
gestaltungsauftrag für die legislative
ja also und was das natürlich heißen
soll ist ein wink mit dem zaunpfahl so
nach dem motto als wir machen die jede
gesetze und ihr dürft natürlich
eingreifen wenn wir es also bunt treiben
aber bitte schreibt uns ansonsten nicht
vor was wir stattdessen hätten machen
sollen so gefährden also jetzt mal sehr
flapsig formuliert aber die frage ist
sozusagen und vielleicht diskutieren wir
das dann gleich noch inwieweit das jetzt
tatsächlich eine aneinanderreihung von
selbstverständlichkeiten ist oder ob da
nicht vielleicht doch ein geschmäckle
dran ist aber vielleicht noch mal das
war jetzt aber auch nicht der einzige
vorwurf erhoben wurde in den
befangenheitsantrag ja noch um zwei
andere aspekte genau also sg richtete
sich übrigens nicht nur gegen den
präsidenten stephan harbarth sondern
auch gegen susanne baer dass es eben
auch eine richterin des ersten senates
und berichterstatterin den zahlreichen
fällen zu bundes notbremse wie gesagt es
sind ich glaube inzwischen über 400
fälle anhängig und die sind übrigens
auch noch nicht entschieden
wir haben so ein paar eilverfahren aber
die hauptsache verfahren die kommen alle
noch und die werden jetzt sind hier
angekündigt für oktober bzw
november wahrscheinlich eher november
und dann wird man sozusagen sehen erst
was ich das bundesverfassungsgericht
jetzt hier zum thema corona beschränkung
alles überlegt hat also wir sind noch in
diesem zwischenstand stadium das ist
vielleicht auch wichtig zu wissen so
könne aber eine von diesen ankündigungen
sind ja jetzt die die beschwerdeführer
in dem verfahren wo jetzt die
befangenheitsanträge gestellt wurden
auch dagegen vorgegangen und sagen da
sehen wir auch irgendwie ein hauch von
befangenheit und zwar weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht angekündigt hat
per pressemitteilung nach vorläufiger
einschätzung ohne mündliche verhandlung
also per beschluss zu entscheiden und
auch darin sehen die die ich sage mal
kläger in dem verfahren einen einen den
bösen schein einer befangenheit ja und
also das argument ist natürlich eine es
gibt nicht so wahnsinnig viele
mündlichen verhandlung vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht das müsste man
an dieser stelle sehr deutlich sagen
genau das sind vielleicht mal ein
dutzend pro jahr wo die tatsächlich
zusammenkommen und wirklich sehr
staatstragend und sehr detailverliebt
diskutieren also das ist wirklich das
sind wirklich diskussionen ich kann nur
jedem raten da mal hin zu fahren
vielleicht bei der sache die einem
interessiert das geht irrsinnig ins
detail da nehmen die sich wahnsinnig
viel zeit und es werden experten rauf
und runter gehört zu jeglicher art von
thema und da geht es wirklich zur sache
es ist schon wirklich ein schauspiel und
es ist sehr beeindruckend ja kann ich
mich nur anschließen wenn man da die
möglichkeit so hat auf jeden fall mal ab
so der mündlichen verhandlung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts und dann
ausgerechnet parcours ohne zusagen nötig
machen wir jetzt mal hier unter uns
ist ich kann schon nachvollziehen dass
man da in rage gerät und das versucht
dann in einen befangenheitsantrag
einzuführen was haben wir noch es war
auch in der tat ein interview kein
interview mehr erwartet
erschienen ist in der tat hat der
kollege reinhard müller geführt mit ihm
wo es also um stefan hat geht er
anschuldigung genau mit dem präsidenten
des bundesverfassungsgerichts stefan
herbert haben sie hat er gesprochen vor
ein paar wochen auch diesen
link kann ich gerne in die schon uns tun
das ist ging natürlich auch um corona es
ging auch um andere dinge
jedenfalls waren dass die vorwürfe die
da herum wurden und das wurde jetzt
rundweg abgelehnt man kann nicht sagen
dass das eine riesen überraschung war
das also bundesverfassungsgericht nicht
sagt ach übrigens stimmt ja jetzt wo er
sagt wir waren befangen richtig das
passiert eher selten allerdings naja
immerhin sind sind in diesem fall ja
sowohl stefan herbert als auch susanne
baer angehört worden und haben eine
interne stellungnahme abgegeben das
heißt es wurde nicht also zumindest
wurden die befangenheitsanträge nicht
als irgendwie evident unzulässig
abgelehnt oder sowas auch schon mal
passiert
das heißt die beiden haben immerhin bei
diesem verfahren quasi also bei dem
eigenen verfahren und bei dem des
anderen oder der anderen nicht mit
entschieden also immerhin gab es
zumindest einen ich sag mal den ansatz
dass für so tragfähig zu halten diese
diesen an möglichen anschein der
befangenheit dass man zumindest mal
gesagt hat das ist nicht komplett
unzulässig und die beiden richter dürfen
nicht mit entscheiden selbst das ist
nämlich beim bundesverfassungsgericht
leider nicht selbstverständlich richtig
gab übrigens ja auch im jüngsten fall wo
eine richterin tatsächlich als befangen
erklärt wurden wir inneren
des ezb verfahrens gab es auch einen
ähnlichen
vorwurf übrigens ging es auch da wie
hoffer im interview in der fas diesmal
also in der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung ja gut so aber jetzt sag
uns doch erstmal kurz mit welchen
gründen hat denn jetzt das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt wir sind
hier nicht befahren also stefan arbeit
und so seine person nicht befangen
kommen also einen teil der vorgebrachten
gründe ist schon gänzlich ungeeignet die
besorgnis der befangenheit abgelehnten
richter zu begründen und der rest ist
jedenfalls unbegründet so und was ist
damit gemeint
also das argument das
bundesverfassungsgericht ist im
wesentlichen
naja also die entscheidung unter in
unsicherheiten ist ja nun ein zeitloses
thema ja das kann man ja auch für die
klimakrise sagen oder für die
zinsentscheidung zum beispiel wurde auch
als beispiel genannt falle ich gesagt so
ein bisschen kühl so nach dem motto na
ja also wie sich die zinsen entwickeln
weil es ja kein mensch das ist ja eine
große unsicherheit das ist jetzt glaube
ich nicht das was man als allererstes
denkt wenn man hier
über die unsicherheit redet das mit
einer weltweiten pandemie war lag schon
eine unglaubliche unsichere situation
vor die natürlich auch ausgefüllt werden
muss wo es wahnsinnig wir
rechtssicherheit gab und übrigens auch
gibt und wahrscheinlich noch ein
weilchen geben wird rechtsunsicherheit
man ja genau was ich gesagt ja
rechtssicherheit nein rechts um sich
noch wahnsinnig viel recht schön wär's
gewesen
also gab es natürlich nicht und wie
gesagt das ist schon auch ein gedanke
den man sofort hat also man kann ja so
ein bisschen als
schutzbehauptungen jetzt vielleicht mal
hier im raum stehen lassen dass man es
so oder so interpretieren kann insgesamt
klingt das ja jetzt muss ich sagen ein
bisschen dünn oder ja also das kann man
schon so sagen also sie haben sich mühe
gegeben hat es jetzt nicht wie du
richtig gesagt hast nicht völlig vom
tisch gewischt aber
ja also dass man jetzt wirklich dafür
eine viel rechtfertigung finden kann
oder jedenfalls eine überzeugende
begründung warum jetzt das gar nichts
mit corona zu tun haben soll und warum
es nicht vielleicht tatsächlich
irgendeinen bösen schein erweckt das hat
sich hier nicht konkret konkret
erschlossen aber wie gesagt alles andere
wäre auch
merkwürdig gewesen vielleicht können wir
gleich noch einmal vertiefen wie wir
solche dinger generell finden und er
kommt aber erst noch einmal zu einem
vergleichbaren genau also eigentlich es
ging ja sogar um dasselbe denn da hat ja
schon mal die afg geklagt und zwar hatte
die afg die mitglieder des zweiten
senats des bundesverfassungsgerichts
ebenfalls wegen befangenheit abgelehnt
da ging es um
dieses verfahren gegen angela merkel
weil die sich geäußert hatte quasi zu
unwählbarkeit von thüringens kurzzeit
ministerpräsident kemmerich und das war
das verfahren um das es ging und da hat
die afg gesagt also leute ihr ist kann
ja wohl nicht wahr sein dass ihr euch in
diesem fall drei wochen vor der
mündlichen verhandlung glaube ich mit
den mitgliedern der bundesregierung
trifft und da hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht und das ist
noch gar nicht lange her im juli 20 21
diesen befangenheitsantrag gegen den
gesamten senat weil die fdp eben damals
nicht wusste wer denn da jetzt
eigentlich genau beteiligt war und so
weiter als offensichtlich unzulässig
abgewiesen so
und das ist schon finde ich auch im
eingang relativ unerfreulich denn wir
haben es jetzt habe ich schon mehrfach
angedeutet auch wenn es natürlich einen
dialog der staatsorgane ist wenn man
sich überlegen kann ist es jetzt per se
ein skandal dass sich sozusagen das
bundesverfassungsgericht als
verfassungsorgan und die bundesregierung
als verfassungsorgan trifft
dann ist es doch zumindest etwas was
geeignet sein kann bei ich sag mal
normalen menschen die sich mit voller
abläufen und mit verläufen am
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht so gut
auskennen
zweifel zu wecken daran ob man denn
komplett unbefangen und unbeeinflusst an
ein verfahren rangehen kann wenn man
sich vor drei wochen noch mit der einen
verfahrens seite getroffen hat so und
dafür finde ich war diese entscheidung
des bundesverfassungsgerichts schon
relativ ruppig also eben
befangenheitsantrag als offensichtlich
unzulässig abgewiesen das heißt die die
richter gegen die sich das gerichtet
haben zum teil sogar mit entschieden
über die eigenen befangenheitsanträge so
absurd hat das bundesverfassungsgericht
diese befangenheitsanträge gefunden und
im wesentlichen begründet das
bundesverfassungsgericht das eben in
diesen damaligen beschluss mit dem ich
fand den begriff sehr schön walten
verschränkung also natürlich sagen die
gibt es die gewaltenteilung aber es gibt
eben auch so die gegenseitige kontrolle
und begrenzung damit die staatsmacht
gemäßigt und die freiheit des einzelnen
geschützt wird und daran sei eben jetzt
das bundesverfassungsgericht als als
hüterin der verfassung sozusagen mit
einer gesamtstaatlichen verantwortung
auch beteiligt und deshalb sei es quasi
ganz normal und usus dass man sich eben
trifft das ist ja eben genauso wie wenn
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgericht ja regelmäßig
repräsentationsaufgaben zusammen mit
anderen obersten verfassungsorgans sie
wahrnimmt so das ist vielleicht der
punkt wo man mal darauf hinweisen kann
dass herr herbert als bundesverfassungs
präsident und kanzlerin merkel oder auch
schäuble als bundestagspräsident sicher
regelmäßig treffen bei solchen
veranstaltungen also es passiert ja ich
weiß jetzt nicht im wochentakt aber
jedenfalls relativ häufig das zu großen
gedenkfeier dann immer alle
verfassungsorgane da sind bei dem großen
zapfenstreich vom reichstag vom
bundestag waren ja auch alle da
natürlich gibt es damit genügend
gelegenheiten die köpfe
zusammenzustecken ja so nebenbei oder
wenn man die zehn minuten vorher oder
danach noch zu nutzen aber muss ist dann
tatsächlich ein dünner sein und in dem
fall eben auch noch drei wochen so vor
der vor der ab verhandlung also diesen
zeitpunkt hatte die afg eben auch
gerügt und da hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt naja ist
ja klar dass wir während dieser
abendessen selbstverständlich nicht über
laufende verfahren sprechen irgendwie
und es ist gebe aber auch wenn das
bundesverfassungsgericht durchaus bei
befangenheit sozusagen wenn es über die
befangenheit anderer richter an anderen
gerichten in deutschland zu entscheiden
hat auf die zeitliche nähe schon ab
stellt würde das aber in diesem fall
nicht gelten auch so ein bisschen ein
argument das latent zirkel schlüssig
klingt nämlich das
bundesverfassungsgericht sah ja immer
mit verfahren gegen die bundesregierung
befasst was da ja auch stimmt und das
heißt diese dann ja wiederum dass die
dass man sich nie treffen könnte weil
irgendein verfahren ja immer an so und
holte sich dann vielleicht auch meine
idee lieber diskutieren könnte das war
ja total verrückte sich nie zum herzen
treffen zum abendessen zu treffen
richtig also es ist so ein bisschen ich
habe da ja auch mal aufgenommen weil das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt eben in
dem aktuellen verfahren das eben von
niko härting für die freien wähler an
angestrengt wurden ist bei den aktuellen
befangenheitsanträgen hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht wirklich mit
einem satz vom tisch gewischt und gesagt
es ist ja per se schon überhaupt gar
kein problem dass wir uns da irgendwie
treffen haben wir schon entschieden
punkt aus ende so und dieses haben wir
schon entschieden war eben dieses afd
verfahren aus dem juli deswegen corinna
vielleicht mal so das allererste so
richtig klar ist mir jetzt nicht was
eigentlich der neue angriffspunkt war
den jetzt rechtsanwalt herting und die
freien wähler
machen wollten um sie jetzt eine neue
befangenheit zu konstruieren aus dem
selben abend essen das finde ich schon
dass man den ziehen kann denn die afg da
davon kann man wirklich mal ausgehen
sind war wirklich nicht gegenstand
dieses amt essens gewesen also
jedenfalls nicht dieser vorfall vor
anderthalb jahren oder was ja aber hier
jetzt ein dinner zum thema zu haben
entscheidung und unsicherheiten das ziel
thierauf corona und wie gesagt corona
war ja auch thema also das ist ja
relativ unstreitig nicht die einzelnen
verfahren sondern wie man sich als
legislative fühlte und als exekutive in
diesem in diesen zeiten ja und welche
rolle vielleicht auch die judikative das
bundesverfassungsgericht dann
einzunehmen hat also ich finde schon
dass man diesen punkt machen kann also
ich fand nachvollziehbar dass man sich
jetzt nicht auf dem af die verfahren
ausruht sondern eben hier auch mal einen
vorstoß machen
jetzt könnte man eben einfach zu der
frage mal kommen ja wie
schwierig finden wir dass tatsächlich
ich würde ja sagen komplette
instinktlosigkeit letztendlich in den
heutigen zeiten findet so ein dinner als
ehrlich gesagt so eine geschichte von
zehn der alten bundesrepublik würde ich
sagen sie in 20 jahren so so würde ich
das sagen so und dass man dann so eine
tradition nicht gleich beerdigt kann ich
irgendwie auch verstehen aber irgendwann
mal das gefühl haben ich weiß nicht ob
das so sinnvoll ist dass wir hier in
diesem rahmen daran festhalten aber dann
macht man es vielleicht nicht auch extra
so dass man auch noch ein aktuelles
thema wird von dem mann dann nachher
erklären muss dass es so aktuell gar
nicht wahr sondern dass es wahnsinnig
zeitlos war ich bin in der sache total
bei dir und ich finde das ehrlich gesagt
ganz erstaunlich beim
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht mein
unter zwei aspekten das erste ist es
geht ja bei der befangenheit immer nicht
darum ist jetzt jemand tatsächlich
befangen sondern es geht um den viel
zitierten bösen schein der böse schein
einer möglicherweise fehlenden
unvoreingenommenheit sagt das
bundesverfassungsgericht immer selbst
und da hast du total recht corinna ich
finde der kann bei menschen die jetzt
mit den strukturen und mit dem
selbstverständnis des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nicht sehr
vertraut sind
definitiv entstehen wenn man sich
irgendwie zum essen trifft und über ein
thema spricht über das man dass ein paar
wochen oder monate später entscheiden
muss und da habe ich muss ich sagen
begrenztes verständnis dafür warum ein
gericht wie das bundesverfassungsgericht
das oft so klug agiert das so
austarierte entscheidungen trifft die
wirklich ja manchmal geradezu
salomonisch sind das ist dann so in
eigener sache sich es oft so einfach
macht und gerade im kontext mit so
politischen
zusammenhängen so völlig dass das
feingefühl in eigener sache irgendwie zu
fehlen scheint das wundert mich wirklich
und das geht eben wirklich schon damit
los wieder mit solchen anträgen
umgegangen wird also solche
formulierungen wie gänzlich ungeeignete
gründe für eine befangenheit oder
offensichtlich unzulässig und so das
vermittelt halt schon ich traue mich
kaum dazu sagen das vermittelt schon
eine gewisse arroganz
kann man schon mal so sagen ja ich finde
das nicht also das ist einfach wirklich
unschlau in eigener sache
gott da sind wir uns jetzt leider wieder
tut uns leid
bundesverfassungsgericht diese kleine
rüge musste sein aber da möchte ich
jetzt pylons zitieren
eine treue gefährtin uns fragt ja keiner
richtig wir werden das nicht lösen sagte
helene letzte woche erstaunlich machen
das jetzt nicht mehr lösen aber ich
finde es wichtig dass wir das einmal
mitgenommen haben denn nur weil wie soll
man sagen weil es oft von seiner
falschen seite gespielt wird nämlich
nämlich häufig von der afg also wo man
dann eben auch versucht sozusagen
zweiflern demokratischen strukturen zu
sehen heißt das ja nicht dass man keine
kritik mehr üben darf und ich finde in
diesen punkten muss man kritik üben
dürfen und ich finde auch dass diese
kritik gerade in den medien zum teil
etwas zu wenig geübt wird
aber nicht von uns dabei wollen wir es
jetzt belassen ja wir sind jetzt schon
wieder so lange wir könnten glaube ich
noch zehn minuten über das thema
diskutieren aber wir belassen es jetzt
dabei und werden und dem spannenden
nächsten thema widmen
ja welches ist es denn liebe pia du hast
uns was mitgebracht vom
bundesarbeitsgericht was war denn da
eigentlich der sachverhalt auch man
könnte vielleicht bei die an dieser
stelle sagen es war tatsächlich das
erste mal dass sich das
bundesarbeitsgericht mit corona
beschäftigt hat genau er ist oder in
diesem zusammenhang so warum regt sich
denn da ging es dann direkt richtig ans
eingemachte da ging es nämlich um eine
400 euro für 450 pardon 450 euro minijob
in die hat glaube ich in bremen
gearbeitet und zwar in einem geschäft
für nähmaschinen und zubehör und dieses
geschäft ist komplett geschlossen worden
wie alle geschäfte
bundesweit und zwar ging ist da um den
zeitraum april 2020 wir erinnern uns ich
glaube mitte märz sind wir so ziemlich
alle in den lockdown geschickt worden
und im april 2020 war alles dicht
aufgrund staatlicher anordnung außer den
supermärkten und kiosken diese
arbeitnehmerin konnte also auch nicht
arbeiten und ihr arbeitgeber hatte ihr
dafür keinen lohn gezahlt darauf haben
sie dann geklagt sie wollte also den
lohn haben für den monat april 20 20 und
zwar aus annahme verzug und hat sich
darauf gestützt dass die sagte die
arbeitgeber dass dein betrieb schließen
muss aufgrund behördlicher anordnung ist
ein risiko und ich würde ja gerne
arbeiten also auch biete mich hier an
aber du nimmst ja meine arbeit gar nicht
an deswegen geht der andere verzug
und
sagt also an mir liegt nicht ich bin
bereit also teil mehr die nun so genau
und normalerweise ist das auch so also
normalerweise geht man davon aus
irgendwie dass wenn sozusagen ein
betrieb seine arbeitnehmer nicht mehr
beschäftigen kann wegen saisongeschäft
oder keine ahnung lieferschwierigkeiten
ist ja im moment ein hippes thema ich
kriege irgendwelche ersatzteile nicht
deshalb stehen die bänder still dann
brauche ich auch meine leute nicht dann
kann ich hatte als arbeitgeber in der
regel nicht sagen so gut gibt nichts zu
tun geht man nach hause gibt keine kohle
so funktioniert nicht sondern
normalerweise trägt eben der arbeitgeber
das risiko dafür dass er seine leute
auch beschäftigen und bezahlen kann so
haben dass hier auch die unteren
instanzen beurteilt aber jetzt kam das
bundesarbeitsgericht genau die sagen
tatsächlich das risiko liegt jedenfalls
nicht beim arbeitgeber genau die sagen
wenn der staat quasi flächendeckend
alles dicht macht was nicht für die
versorgung der bevölkerung absolut
notwendig ist dann realisiert sich damit
kein im betrieb des arbeitgebers
angelegtes risiko und dass die
arbeitnehmerin ihrer arbeitsleistung
deshalb also nicht erbringen konnte
seine vielmehr folge eines hoheitlichen
eingriffsverfahren
die gesellschaft insgesamt zu schützen
und dann sei es auch nicht sache des
arbeitgebers sondern des staates
gegebenenfalls dafür zu sorgen dass die
die entstehende nachteile adäquat
ausgeglichen werden so und das hat der
staat ja durchaus in weiten teilen auch
getan er hat ja das kurzarbeitergeld
sozusagen den den zugang zum
kurzarbeitergeld erleichtert also jeder
betrieb konnte kann ja kurzarbeitergeld
beantragen ob das jetzt irgendwie einen
oder 1000 mitarbeitende gibt ist egal
und dann zahlt die bundesagentur für
arbeit an die arbeitnehmer ich glaube am
anfang waren das 60 und sogar später 70
prozent des nettolohns sodass wurde
sogar verlängert bis ende 20 21 eben
wegen corona und der staat zahlt dann
pauschaliert auch die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge die
normalerweise die betriebe auch in
kurzarbeit zahlen müssen dh der staat
ist hier schon relativ massiv
eingesprungen problem der damit die
jetzt betroffen war kurzarbeitergeld
gibt es nur wenn man
versicherungspflichtig beschäftigten das
rund 450 euro minijobber sind nicht
versicherungspflichtig beschäftigt das
sei also will sagen keine
arbeitslosenversicherung keine renten
abgaben all das bezahlt in diesem
zusammenhang einer weder arbeitgeber
noch arbeitnehmer
und deswegen nicht
sozialversicherungspflichtig hat so
heißt die geringfügig beschäftigten
wurden schlicht vergessen ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob sie vergessen worden
sind ehrlich gesagt man könnte ja auch
davon ausgehen dass ist eine
risikoverteilung ist die man in kauf
genommen hat
also am ende geht es ja um eine
risikoverteilung das war ja wie in so
vielen konstellationen vom staat
vergessen du hast total recht also wir
haben hier jede komische konstellation
schuldige dass ich da so unterbrechen
wir haben die komische konstellation
dass man ja schon auch sagen mussten her
klar also dass der kiosk besitzer hat
sich zahlen muss ist auch irgendwie
verständlich was kann der denn dafür
deswegen hätte man das vielleicht
durchaus auch als gerechte unter packen
können wie du es ja vorgeschlagen heißt
ich hatte dazu vorgeschlagen corinna
weil es nicht drin haben weil sie sich
nicht sicher war ob sie das gerecht
findet ja genau auf der anderen seite
hat man doch dann irgendwie das gefühl
da aber so ganz also wenn ihr nun jedem
aus der patsche geholfen wurde ja auch
zu recht weil es eben so eine besondere
situation war es sind ja nun hilfen
geschlossen ohne ende vielleicht hat
übrigens auch der kiosk besitzer geld
bekommen für die mietzahlung oder was
auch immer man kann's konnten ja alle
möglichen unternehmer jetzt geld
beantragen wirtschaftshilfen beantragen
nur jetzt die geringfügig beschäftigten
und das sind ja viele ja die bekommen
gar nicht dass schon ein bisschen
komisch also die arbeiten in der
hotellerie die arbeiten in den
restaurants als putzhilfen überall sind
die ja ja und trotzdem fand ich also man
kann schon etwas überrascht sein über
das urteil wenn man das das erste mal
liest denkt man in der tat hoch aber ich
glaube das liegt auch so ein bisschen
daran dass das arbeitsrecht in aller
regel in deutschland ja tendenziell
relativ arbeitnehmerfreundlich ausfällt
arbeitnehmerfreundlich auch
aber ich fand es auf der anderen seite
nicht ganz so dramatisch weil ich denke
schon dass ein 450 euro job der weg
fällt wahrscheinlich nicht existenz
bedroht und sein dürfte denn am ende
ging es ja darum wenn man sagt man man
muss das risiko irgendwie verteilen und
der staat ist hier in großem ausmaß
eingesprungen dann ging es ja darum dass
die leute die dann halt von ihrem
vollzeitlohns 60 prozent über kurzarbeit
bekommen haben dass man davon ausgehen
ja mit 60 prozent seines einkommens
kannst halt irgendwie noch überleben
deine miete bezahlen und das das
notwendigste kriegst du damit irgendwie
noch hin und ich denke und ist also
zumindest wenn ich jetzt mal so zu sagen
gut will ich unterstelle dass die 450
euro jobber nicht einfach vergessen
wurden kann man das schon gut damit
begründen dass man sagt naja mit 450
euro job stocke ich im zweifel auf der
ist aber wahrscheinlich nicht dafür da
alles existenz notwendige bei mir jetzt
zu begleichen weil es kann ja ohnehin
keiner mit 450 euro tun ja man muss
ehrlicherweise sagen dann schickte in
die all in hartz iv mit allen
konsequenzen also kann man so machen
dann kann man ja sagen der staat
fängt hier so oder so auf wir haben das
netz mit hartz4 aber das ist nicht
angenehm das würde ich hier nun
sozusagen ein mal so teuer man konnte
sich ja schon noch einen anderen job
suchen das war jetzt nicht so dass da
niemand irgendwie
450 euro jobber rinne und war gesucht
hätte also das ging ja schon auch also
pizza austräger zb die wurden ja viel
gesucht und in den supermärkten sowie
also nun dafür sogar märkte genau also
bestimmt ne also lässt sich so oder so
vertreten ich fand jedenfalls
interessant dass das
bundesarbeitsgericht sehr deutlich wahr
auch mit dem
mit dem sound frei gewunken hat man so
schön sagt und gesagt hat hier gibt es
offensichtlich eine lücke im gesetz kann
man haben also kann man gut finden
könnte man aber auch schließen ja also
ich vermute nicht dass das jetzt
nachträglich noch passiert und es ist
natürlich so ein bisschen spannend dazu
habe ich mir jetzt abschließend noch gar
keine meinung gebildet aber ich wollte
zumindest hier nochmal reinschmeißen das
möglicherweise eben nicht nur 450 euro
jobberin und aber davon betroffen sind
sondern auch andere leute die aus
irgendwelchen gründen kein
kurzarbeitergeld bekommen hätte zum
beispiel leute die dänen schon gekündigt
worden war das habe ich irgendwo gelesen
dass ein arbeitsrechtler geschrieben
also im prinzip um alle die kein
kurzarbeitergeld bekommen hätten und
leute die zum beispiel schon gekündigt
worden wären und dann für die monate
noch gehalt bekommen haben da könnte der
arbeitgeber jetzt theoretisch hingehen
und sagen ich möchte mein geld zurück
also da gibt es durchaus so ein paar
implikationen über die man noch mal
nachdenken muss genauso die frage gilt
das tatsächlich für alle wenn das ein
lockdown für alle war oder könnte man
auch sagen na ja zum beispiel bei einem
friseur oder bei einem keine ahnung
masseur oder ein anlagen studio also bei
körpernahen dienstleistungen da ist ja
das system die ganze zeit davon
ausgegangen dass das diese läden per sie
gefährlicher sind corona zu verbreiten
und wäre dass dann möglicherweise eine
andere bewertung mit dem endergebnis
dass man sagen würde na ja aber da trägt
der arbeitgeber dann doch wieder das
betriebsrisiko und muss doch seine leute
bezahlen auch die 450 euro jobber weil
er quasi aus seinem betrieb das risiko
geschaffen hatte da gab es auch einige
arbeitsrechtler das vertreten haben also
ganz normal kurzen und das war eben das
brg kann ja wie immer nur entscheiden
was ihm vorgelegt wird aber das ist
vielleicht jetzt auch noch nicht so
final und für alle durch entschieden wie
sich das auf den ersten blick an hat
aber
final ausdiskutiert jedenfalls für uns
hier noch mal genau
da wollen wir doch jetzt mal einen punkt
setzen und jetzt kommen wir zum
schwerpunktthema diese woche viel
vergnügen sag ich da
ja in den anstehenden
koalitionsverhandlungen der ampel
scheint ja einst schon fast zur
gewissheit geworden zu sein nämlich dass
cannabis wahrscheinlich legalisiert wird
jedenfalls gibt es dafür eine doch recht
starke koalition deshalb kocht die
debatte natürlich jetzt gerade wieder
hoch und da haben sich ja inzwischen
viele eingeschaltet polizisten juristen
soziologen suchtberater die cannabis
industrie die immer professioneller wird
aber heute machen wir mal was ganz
anderes
wir reden jetzt mal mit einem
verbraucher also möchte ich mal nennen
der die volle härte des gesetzes gespürt
hat also sagen kann was es bedeutet dass
der herr cannabis genoss in deutschland
zwar verboten ist aber in kleinmengen
immerhin geduldet wird jedenfalls wenn
es die polizei erlaubt und die
staatsanwaltschaft ich weiß das genau
bedeutet erzählt uns heute florian
leider erst politikstudent aus wird wo
florian schön dass du heute mit dabei
wirst ja hallo und danke für die
einladung vielleicht kurz mal zur
erklärung wir kennen uns gar nicht aber
wir duzen uns trotzdem weich chlor ihren
dass du aufgedrängt habe ganz entgegen
meiner üblichen gepflogenheiten ja aber
irgendwie dachte ich wenn es um das
thema geht kann man nicht mit dem
gestellten sie daher kommt es in ordnung
nicht ja für mich passt es auch gut
super
florian du hast deine geschichte auch
auf twitter erzählt du wurdest mit
cannabis erwischt und hass wie gesagt
dann die konsequenzen zu spüren bekommen
erzähl doch vielleicht mal was war da
los
genau also ich wurde mit 19 jahren von
der polizei aufgegriffen jetzt nicht im
straßenverkehr oder so sondern auf einer
hausparty in dem rahmen hat es statt
gefunden dass ich so du warst in so
einer wohnung ja und genau das war gar
nicht irgendwie draußen also ich war
nicht im straßenverkehr das wurde
nämlich auf twitter öfter auch
geschrieben ob das denn der fall gewesen
sei aber das war eben in der wohnung und
da ist zu möchte ich gar nicht zu sehr
darauf eingehen aber da ist auf jeden
fall die polizei gekommen und hatte dann
bei mir auch gras gefunden und genau das
hat dann einen ziemlich langwierigen
prozess aus löst der
das ende vom lied für mich war dass sich
9000 euro zahlen musste
durch verschiedene kosten die entstanden
sind durch gericht durch die mpu durch
verschiedene analysen dass ich jetzt
auch clean sei die dann ja meiner
meinung nach nicht genau genug waren und
also das können wir gleich nochmal
auseinanderklaffen vielleicht noch
einmal sozusagen auch für fürs protokoll
du wurdest auch mit dieser typischen
eigenbedarfs menge erwischt also du
hattest jetzt keinen koffer mit gras bei
dir sondern das ist ja genau der punkt
nennen das in deutschland ja so eine
sehr merkwürdige rechtliche lage gibt
dass es einerseits haben wir hier stehen
bis zu fünf jahre haft oder geldstrafe
auf den unerlaubten anbau von cannabis
den handel erwerb und besitz aber
handelt es sich um eine geringe menge
zum eigenverbrauch so gibt das gesetz
der staatsanwaltschaft die möglichkeit
von der strafverfolgung abzusehen so ist
die rechtslage und du warst in diesem
eigengebrauch bereich oder genau also
die menge die gefunden wurde bei mir in
berlin wäre diese menge überhaupt nicht
verfolgt worden aber ich habe zu dem
zeitpunkt in bayern nicht aufgehalten
und in bayern ist der eigenbedarf ab
über sechs gramm
überschritten und das hat sich der
polizei entsprechend genau überschritten
und da hat die polizei dann auch direkt
angenommen ich sei dealer es bei mir zu
hause auch nachts um drei in die wohnung
also ins haus meiner eltern aufgeweckt
einnehmen gleichen abend genau das ist
noch nichts passiert weil eben die
polizei davon ausgegangen ist da ich so
eine große menge die eben in berlin ja
nicht mehr verfolgt werden würde bei mir
hatte dass das schon ausgereicht hat
dann bei mir nacht zum 3 mein zimmer zu
durchsuchen
wenn du ihm war es damals 19 jahre alt
wie war denn das ist jetzt auch nicht so
lange her da kann man sagen du mit mitte
20 sei willkommen wir verraten aber wie
war denn da im grunde genommen so die
stimmung auch man hat es ja vielleicht
auch nicht alleine gemacht wenn man es
ist ja keine besonders einsame tätigkeit
die man da macht er war es eine super
überraschung als die polizei da rein
raus oder musste man tatsächlich
immer damit rechnen dass so was mal
passieren kann wie würdest du das
beschreiben
ich würde sagen damals hatte ich so zwei
herzen die in meiner brust geschlagen
haben zum einen als junger mensch dann
denkt man ja auch immer man ist hier
unbesiegbar und perfekt und einem selbst
würde sowas ja nie passieren auf der
anderen seite hatte ich schon in meinem
bekanntenkreis auch schon fälle wo die
polizei dann den leuten einfach mal zum
beispiel auch eine geschichte die
passiert ist so die polizei hat da gab
es eine streich für die hat auf dem dorf
pause gemacht und da hatte eine person
bei sich zuhause geraucht und die
polizei hat das gerochen und hat halt
ihnen dann direkt hoch genommen also da
kann auch selbst im eigenen zuhause kann
es dann passieren das zufälligerweise
nebenan jemand steht und dann ist man
halt dran
dementsprechend eigentlich habe ich
schon auch ein stück weit kommen sehen
aber trotzdem ist dann im moment wenn es
dann so weit ist natürlich die panik
groß und dann dann ist es halt so weit
dann kann man sich auch nicht mehr
entziehen sag mal wie auf der anderen
seite wie schwierig ist es denn
eigentlich anderen stoff ranzukommen
also das gibt's ja nun nicht gerade in
coffeeshops bei uns das ist ja nur
einfach so also man muss schon wissen wo
man den här kriegt aber wie würdest du
das beschreiben es war das für dich
schwer für dich und deine bekannten oder
relativ einfach
ich denke mal auch da ist es sehr
abhängig von welchen menschen man kennt
und in welchem umfeld man sich aufhält
ich bin mir sicher es gibt viele leute
die überhaupt keine möglichkeit sehen
würden aus als in parks irgendwelche
leute ansprechen die so aussehen als
würden sie die len aber sobald man
einmal wirklich kontakt er hat in szene
und das kann sehr schnell gehen einfach
allein in meiner schule kannte ich schon
auch lange bevor ich gekauft habe wusste
ich wär da somit grass unterwegs ist
wenn man da mal ansprechen kann
dementsprechend genauer waren das auch
dann meine ersten kontakte dass ich dann
mal jemand gefragt habe ob ich damit
kommen kann und dann
quasi der erste kontakt mit einem dealer
war dann natürlich so dass ich dahin
gegangen bin und auch was wollte noch
unter 18 dann hat er mich aber nach dem
ausweis gefragt und dann konnte ich mir
nichts kaufen kleiner scherz hat also
sinn galt deswegen jugendliche kommen
überall an jeder ecke wenn sie wollen an
gras kann das ist einfach nur eine frage
des einkommens wird und bei dir ja auch
klassenkameraden also man muss ich jetzt
gar nicht so mit ganz dunklen typen
einlassen sondern das ist schon relativ
gang und gäbe genau also dieses
stereotyp von wegen da kommt dann
irgendwie ein erwachsener an die schule
und fertigt ist hat zumindest bei mir
überhaupt nicht so gezogen sondern bei
mir waren das gleichaltrige teilweise
jüngere leute noch
die halt dann aus irgendeinem grund
kontakt hatten der wo sie halt dann
daran gekommen sind also kann man
wirklich überhaupt nicht einschätzen wer
das macht und wer das nicht macht vom
aus dann kommen wir doch noch mal zurück
zu dem abend also das muss man sich
vorstellen du bist auf dieser party dann
kommt die polizei
nimmt dich hoch sozusagen und fährt dann
wahrscheinlich auch direkt mit dir nach
hause und macht da noch also nachts um 3
die hausdurchsuchungen so wie du es eben
geschildert hat ist also richtig genau
das wurde dann direkten
durchsuchungsbefehle beordert
wegen gefahr im verzug war sehr
wichtiger hinweis na also ganz so
lapidar wie ich das jetzt eben
geschildert hat geht es natürlich nicht
die können nicht einfach sozusagen zu
dir rein und das dann klar machen
sondern da wird dann tatsächlich auch
der richter der jeweilige zuständige
amtsrichter der bereitschaft hat muss
dann einen durchsuchungsbefehl erlassen
so war wahrscheinlich auch jetzt hier in
deinem fall der gang der dinge genau und
da möchte ich auch eine sache noch mal
klarstellen und zwar was er eben auch
oft gesagt würde den so von
konsumierenden seite der polizei und
justiz auch vorgeworfen wird dass die
leute viel zu rabiat gegenüber gras
konsumentinnen vorgehen würden das kann
den fällen auch so sein zumindest bei
mir hatte ich gar nicht das gefühl dass
jetzt da die polizei oder der richter
der mich dann letztendlich auch
verurteilt hat dass der mich sehr stark
nochmal verhält unverhältnismäßig
gehandelt hätte sondern ich habe das
gefühl dass sowohl polizei als auch
justiz sich halt an diese vorlagen
halten die ihrer meinung nach dann halt
einfach rechts sind und ja so ist es ja
dann letztendlich auch also ich würde ja
auch rechtmäßig letztendlich verurteilt
so wird halt gemacht in bayern und du
sagst du zu recht in berlin wäre das
anders gewesen in anderen bundesländern
sind die handhabung da sehr
unterschiedlich du würdest sagen das war
so ein bisschen standard procedure bei
dir die haben es gemacht wie bei 1 wie
ging es dann weiter
ja erst mal war dann so die große
ungewissheit was überhaupt passiert ist
ja auch oft so einen juristischen
verfahren das man dann erstmal warten
muss und erst mal die mühlen mahlen
lassen muss letztendlich hatte ich dann
aus angst weil ich nicht wusste was
passiert jetzt die haben wir mit einer
hausdurchsuchung gemacht vielleicht
denken die ich bin dealer das ist ja
dann auch mal eine ganz andere
geschichte ob ich jetzt konsument bin
oder mir vorgeworfen würde ich würde
verkaufen und da habe ich dann mein
anwalt genommen und bin dann eben mit
diesem anwalt vor gericht dann hätte
genau vor gericht gegangen und dort es
war eine sehr kurze verhandlung da wurde
ich schnell abgeurteilt im prinzip der
richter hat gesagt dass ich ja noch ein
junger heranwachsender sei und ich ja
auch reue zeigen würde und
dementsprechend möchte er mich jetzt
nicht besonders hart verurteilen das
urteil war letztendlich dass ich ein
jahr abstinenz nachweisen muss dass ich
700 euro an eine gemeinnützige
organisation die zur drogenberatung auch
tätig ist spenden soll und dass sich
fünf beratungsstunden bei auch so eine
organisation
in anspruch nehmen muss wie weist man
den die abstinenz nach ein jahr lang
gibt es zumindest meines wissens nach
zwei möglichkeiten zum einen und das
kennen wahrscheinlich die meisten ist
die urinkontrolle das bedeutet dass
innerhalb von einem jahr sechs mal eine
es ist keine behörde man möchte immer
behörde sagen aber es ist eine private
firma die diese urin kontrollen
durchführen und die auch die mpu die
medizinisch-psychologische untersuchung
durchführen um die fahrerlaubnis wieder
zu bekommen diese behörden machen quasi
auch die tests dafür dass man nachweisen
kann vor gericht dass man wieder clean
ist und genau also eben es gibt theorien
kontrollen da muss man immer auf abruf
innerhalb von 24 stunden dort auftauchen
und dann eben einmal wasser lassen und
dann gibt es da getestet und die kommen
überraschend also dann kann sich nicht
darauf vorbereiten man kriegt keinen
termin in drei wochen muss man den
puffer an tanzen sondern das ist relativ
kurzfristig oder genau eben innerhalb
von 24 stunden ist es gibt insgesamt im
jahr acht wochen die man vorangemeldet
sagen kann ich bin jetzt verreist also
ich habe jetzt nicht die möglichkeit
innerhalb von 24 stunden zu kommen da
muss man aber dann auch sagen wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel als student meinen
eltern mal besuchen fahrers wochenende
und dann noch den freitag gefahren bin
und den montag noch da bin dann müsste
ich diese tage auch schon anmelden weil
es kann ja sein dass die mir
sonntagabend schreiben ist eine
montagmittag da oder bis montag 14 uhr
und das war zumindest für mich dann mit
den reisewegen von meiner studenten
statt zu meinen eltern schon sehr
schwierig nur noch einzuhalten also
fange ich auch relativ eng getaktet
deswegen habe ich nicht die urin
kontrolle gemacht sondern hat nämlich
für die haaranalyse entschieden da wird
zweimal innerhalb von einem jahr also
alle sechs monate werden einem beschlag
abgeschnitten und
von dem chemischen labor untersucht auf
verschiedene drogen und das ist eben der
vorteil dass man nur alle sechs monate
dahin muss und nicht zu diesem ständigen
kontrolle gefühl unterliegt
genau das dachte ich mir dass das eine
gute idee ist
nach den ersten sechs monaten war das
ergebnis auch negativ entsprechend habe
ich dann die mpu auch schon direkt nach
dem ich das zweite h die zweite analyse
abgegeben habe und nicht direkt schon
zur stelle gegangen habe gesagt ich habe
alles bereit ich mache es die mpu hatte
dann auch eben diesen medizinischen
psychologischen und den kognitiven tests
sind ja drei tests die menschen
rückführen muss hatte die auch bestanden
hat quasi ein vorläufiges bestanden
bekommen und dann eine woche später kam
der große schock dass diese haaranalyse
die zweite die ich abgegeben hatte
nachdem ich also schon mal klien war man
kann jetzt auch nicht sagen dass ein
restbestände von davor diese analyse
wurde dann positiv also ich bin
durchgefallen also du hattest woche lang
nicht gegriffen monatelang oder was und
trotzdem hat sich das in den haaren
irgendwie anders dargestellt weiß man
woran es liegt
meine große vermutung ist dass ich zu
besuch bei einer befreundeten wg war und
diese wg hat auch gekifft oder leute
dort haben gekämpft und die haben als
ich dabei auf dem balkon gekifft und ich
bin in der wohnung geblieben also ich
hatte wirklich jetzt nicht sehr nahen
kontakt dazu sondern halt so ein
bisschen was in der luft gehangen hat
aber das hat scheinbar schon ausgereicht
weil ich hatte keine anderen kontakte
dazu das hat scheinbar schon ausgereicht
diese diese analyse zu verfälschen und
da möchte ich auch noch kurz dazu sagen
es gibt möglichkeiten herauszufinden
chemische möglichkeiten zu sehen ob das
aktiver konsum ist also wirklich das an
an dem thc ziehen und das in den körper
in hohen konzentrationen aufzunehmen
oder ob es passiv konsum ist also dieses
es ist noch ein bisschen was in der luft
das in verschiedene moleküle die sich im
körper ablagern und es gibt
möglichkeiten die auch
spezifisch herauszufiltern aber das wird
in deutschland nicht gemacht sondern
analyse und das war mir einfach nicht
bewusst da hätte ich wahrscheinlich mehr
noch recherchieren müssen diese analysen
werden in deutschland leider sehr
ungenau ausgewertet das heißt es ist
sehr leicht und das ist auch schon
vielen konsumierenden passiert dass sie
eben wegen der analyse weise diese form
gewählt haben dann ich sag jetzt mal
fälschlicherweise positive ergebnisse
bekommen haben aber das hat die behörde
natürlich oder die mpu stelle natürlich
anders gesehen die sagen ich glaube ist
ein bisschen über dem wert dann bis sei
durchgefallen und was passiert dann wenn
man durchfällt also um viel ist
vielleicht übrigens auch noch mal
deutlich zu machen auch das waren ja
kosten die duh die die zahlen musste ist
eine für diese haaranalyse wie teuer war
dies genau die haaranalyse kostet ich
meine es sind 350 euro pro user also
jetzt wollen wir dich da auch gar nicht
festnageln oder mit manchmal so ein
gefühl bekommt und dann bist du
durchgefallen was passierte dann
ja bei mir war nochmal eine besondere
situation folgende dass ich den a1 also
den mopedführerschein den hatte ich
schon gesessen und war gerade dabei
sowohl den nächstgrößeren also den a2
führerschein zu machen und auch die
fahrerlaubnis fürs auto geraten im
prozess zu sein ich war bei beiden
direkt vor der prüfung beziehungsweise
die motorrad prüfung hatte ich sogar
schon bestanden und den bestandenen
zettel hatte ich schon aber das war noch
nicht in der fahrerlaubnis eingetragen
und bestandene prüfungen da verfällt die
gültigkeit nach einem jahr und bei einem
fahrschul stunden verfallen die
oder sind die fristen bis man man dann
fertig sein muss zwei jahre und dadurch
dass ich jetzt ein jahr quasi
verschwendete zeit hatte und noch mal im
jahr nachweisen musste dass ich clean
bin sind alle diese stunden auch
verfallen plus die ich denke mal es
waren 1600 euro für diese erste mpu und
mit dem ganzen haaranalyse und die mpu
kostet ja auch relativ viel da habe ich
auf jeden fall richtig viel geblecht was
mit der fahrerlaubnis zu tun hatte und
dann muss ich ja noch mal die urin
kontrollen machen was dann auch noch mal
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher irgendwas
zwischen 800000 euro gekostet haben über
das ganze jahr verteilt plus dann
nochmal die mpu die ich meine so 650
euro kostet
also wirklich sehr viel aufwand muss man
sagen
wie war denn wie hast du eigentlich dass
gerichtsverfahren
wahrgenommen
schuldig jetzt den schritt zurück aber
darüber müssen wir vielleicht einfach
nur mal ganz kurz sprechen wie lange das
gedauert hat wie
schwierig es war du hast schon gesagt
der richter hat sich eigentlich gnädig
gezeigt aber gnädig heißt ja dann
immerhin noch die konsequenzen die du ja
schon geschildert hast ne genau also zum
einen der vorfall war im august und
letztendlich das urteil wurde im märz
gesprochen april zu mir dazu gestellt
also allein da sind schon mal neun
monate ins land gegangen in denen ich so
auf ja in unwissenheit irgendwie der
dinge gewartet habe
und da will ich jetzt auch gar nicht
vorwerfen ich weiß und die leute haben
viel zu tun aber ist natürlich trotzdem
unangenehm für einen selbst und
genau ist gerichtsverfahren selber wurde
das in einem tag abgehandelt oder zieht
sich so was dann auch das ging dann sehr
schnell tatsächlich also ich habe mir
eben anwalt genommen dieser anwalt hat
sich dann auch mit dem richter getroffen
schon davor und da gab es dann schon
glaube ich so
ja ich will es nicht absprachen sagen
aber da wurde schon mal so der
erwartungshorizont ein bisschen
abgeklopft und
dementsprechend genau man muss dann auch
zu seiner oder ich musste zumindest zu
einer
jugendberatungsstelle so das war von der
stadt in der ich wohne eine person die
dann der behörde sitzt und so ein
bisschen mein soziales umfeld dann mal
bei mir abgehört hat und so eine
prognose abgegeben hat wie jetzt mein
zukünftiges verhalten sein würde und ich
hatte sehr stark das gefühl dass dieses
gespräch mit dieser frau sehr stark auf
den richter eingewirkt hatte sie hatte
geschrieben ich empfehle geldstrafe
suchtprävention oder sucht
beratungstermine und ein jahr abstinenz
und das ist dann auch im prinzip das was
im urteil ausgang aber das ziel ist dann
schon dicht im grunde genommen von dem
zeug los zu bekommen
es steht am ende
dass das ganzes ganzen aufwand das ist
jedenfalls ein genau ein wichtiges ziel
ich hatte das gefühl das war die ganze
zeit über war das immer so ein bisschen
zucker und peitsche also die beiden erst
sehr stark und sehr eindrücklich so dass
auf jeden fall die
falls es ein nächstes mal geben sollte
da sehr große angst da ist wenn man mit
dem zeug in kontakt kommt weil auch es
ist ja so wenn ich ein erstes mal
erwischt werde ist es immer noch
verhältnismäßig kommt man glimpflich
davon wenn es jetzt nicht mehr die
großen mengen sind aber sobald es dann
ein zweites oder sogar drittes mal
passiert was ja auch bei leuten der fall
ist dann kann es heldt auf einmal in
viel höhere strafen gehen und da ja ist
natürlich auch was das im hinterkopf das
immer mit kommt vor allem eben wenn
jetzt zum beispiel wie ich ich finde
einfach dass wenn man sich anschaut dass
in unserer bevölkerung sehr viel alkohol
konsumiert wird sehr viel tabak
konsumiert wird auch koffein ist eine
droge im prinzip cannabis es halt auch
eine droge die berauscht ja die auch
körperliche schäden und psychische
folgen haben kann ja aber es gibt auch
dort einen konsumverhalten das nichts
krankhaft ist sondern dass es gibt so
viele menschen die in im öffentlichen
dienst sind oder auch irgendwelche
anderen leistungsträger in der
gesellschaft sind die konsumieren und
die das jetzt halt versteck machten
müssen und sich dann irgendwie auf dem
schwarzmarkt irgendwelche
unbekannten cannabis sorten holen müssen
einfach weil das die einzige möglichkeit
ist die sie haben um an das zeug
ranzukommen und ja diese menschen sind
nicht hängen kiffer die ganze zeit nur
zum sitzen und nichts machen sondern die
arbeiten den ganzen tag und machen dann
halt statt sich ein bier auf abends
zünden die sich halt eine tüte an naja
jetzt sind leiten wir auch schon langsam
zu dem zweiten punkt den wir besprechen
wollten du setzt dich haben das mag
vielleicht jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
überraschend tatsächlich auch für die
legalisierung von cannabis ein
was würdest du dir den jetzt wünschen
von der aktuellen oder von der sich
formierenden bundesregierung
also zum einen würde ich mir wünschen
dass sie das thema ernst nehmen und auch
bald mal eine aussage tätigen zumindest
dass es auf dem schirm haben und dass
die legalisierung kommt das ist ja noch
nicht es scheint jetzt schon sicher zu
sein aber meiner meinung nach ist das
jetzt noch nicht in trockenen tüchern
es gibt ja auch die ideen erstmal
modellprojekte zum beispiel zu machen
meiner meinung nach sollte die regierung
jetzt die gelegenheit beim schopfe
packen und jetzt da einfach mal ein
sauberes gesetz vorliegen zum beispiel
die grünen haben ja schon sehr sehr
ausgearbeitet ist und auch mit expertin
ein gesprochenes gesetz schon vorgelegt
darauf könnte aufgebaut werden und was
ich mir sehr wünschen würde ist zum
einen das nicht dieser vorschlag dass in
den apotheken das gras dann verkauft
würde umgesetzt wird sondern dass es
fachgeschäfte gibt dementsprechend auch
ausgebildete verkäufer innen haben wo es
auch klar ist ich kann da jetzt rein
gehen ohne dass ein kind auf einmal
neben mir steht weil das ich weiß nicht
halsweh hat und mit der mutter in die
apotheke das ist erst ein bisschen
dieser charme effekt der in der apotheke
keine rolle spielen würde oder das
spielt auch mit dazu ja natürlich und es
fühlt sich halt auch glaube ich für alle
besser an wenn es eine quasi ein
sicheres umfeld zum einen zum schutz vor
für jugendliche ist das dass die da
nicht einfach rein können klar das geht
bei der apotheke gut da können sie schon
rein über sie können kaufen aber ja ich
empfinde es irgendwie als quatsch dass
daneben alkohol und tabak zum beispiel
in supermärkten verkaufen will teilweise
auf irgendwie einem meter höhe so dass
kinder das eigentlich noch greifen
könnten der alkohol noch die stamperl
dastehen und
dann irgendwie ihr kann er bis auf
einmal nur noch in der apotheke so
eingefügt mit rezepten kommen werden
kann so aber jetzt kann er was im
supermarkt wäre jetzt auch nicht ein
ziel du würdest fachgeschäfte
präferieren es wäre doch zum beispiel
die idee zu sagen es gibt fachgeschäfte
die einfach drogen verkaufen also wo man
dann sagt alkohol tabak und
da müsste man es dann erst mal
diskutieren welche wirklich aber dass so
was dass das einfach grundsätzlich
ausgelagert wird das weil ich finde es
auch ein bisschen
also ich finde es sinnvoll dazu sagen es
gibt halt die möglichkeit wohin zu gehen
aber es ist jetzt nicht das was ich mir
jetzt neben den täglichen einkauf
einfach noch so mitnehmen
jetzt hast du ja schon auf alkohol und
zigaretten hingewiesen und das ist
natürlich auch ein wohlfeiles argumente
allerdings kann man es natürlich auch
umdrehen und dann sagen na ja also quasi
der verweis auf die eine räuberbande
rechtfertigt nicht das verhalten der
anderen zu ungefähr nimm mein als man
könnte dieses argument natürlich auch
nehmen und dann gleichzeitig für den
sehr unrealistische verbot von alkohol
und zigaretten
nutzen
was ich jetzt aber eigentlich ganz gerne
die fragen würde ist wie bekommt man in
so eine legalisierung hin oder ich
möchte mal anders formulieren besteht
nicht die gefahr dass man dann einfach
einen freifahrtschein erteilt und sagt
dass man auf so ungefährlich ist dieses
zeug gar nicht gehört ihr könnt kiffen
so wie ihr wollt und vielleicht du hast
es vorhin schon erwähnt aber ich möchte
einmal noch deutlich sagen also gerade
bei jugendlichen und heranwachsenden
deren gehirn sich noch sehr verändert
und sehr stark auf solche dinge reagiert
kann das natürlich auch wirklich in die
hose gehen es gibt psychiatrien die
haben oder in psychiatrie sind
sind jugendliche die auf psychosen
hängenbleiben oder psychosen durch
solche konsum bekommen haben gang und
gäbe ja das muss man eben auch sehen
aber wie sozusagen bekommt man es da hin
dass das dann nicht als freifahrschein
wahrgenommen wird ich denke im gegenteil
jetzt ist es gerade einen
freifahrtschein sollte man einmal diese
grenze überwunden hat im kopf dass es
illegal ist ist
es ja quasi so als wenn man in der
geschworenen oder eingeschworenen
gemeinschaft in der die kiffer innen
zusammenhalten und da irgendwie jetzt
sollen wir gegen die aufgebaut wird und
gerade bei einer legalisierung empfinde
ich es als diesen großen vorteil dass es
viel einfacher ist auch menschen
hilfsangebote zum beispiel anzubieten
also nehmen wir einfach noch mal ein
beispiel in aller kürze ich hatte diese
fünf sucht beratungstermine das waren 5
gespräche die ich mit einer älteren
person geführt habe die auch jetzt nicht
schlecht waren oder so aber die haben
mich in meinem verhalten überhaupt nicht
beeinflusst und da könnte es wenn es
legale möglichkeiten gibt es im gras zu
erwerben auch dort zielgruppen gemäß
ich sag mal werbung für solche
beratungsgespräche oder auch therapien
geben so dass leute auch wirklich
nummern haben an die sie sich einfach
wenn das sie nicht angst haben dann eben
erst mal die peitsche spüren zu müssen
bevor sie dann vielleicht auch hilfe
bekommen was auch heute sehr viele leute
davon abhält überhaupt mal da irgendwie
aktiv zu werden weil sie repressalien
fürchten dass rechtsstaates gehört auf
diesem wege sozusagen deutlich wird hier
ist wo der hase haschisch konsumiert
deswegen ist man hat man probleme und
dass man sozusagen neben der therapie
dann auch noch gleich das strafverfahren
am hals bekommt oder genau was genau
also das ist ein grund könne und was
auch nochmal zu dem thema
psychosen und was das mit legalisierung
was da noch passieren würde
ich kann es natürlich jetzt nicht
empirisch schon bestätigen aber was
meine erfahrung ist und dass da kann ich
auch viele andere leute die das
bestätigen würden heute kauft man immer
dieser die katze im sack wenn man
irgendwo gras auf der straße oder bei
irgendwelchen er freund in den kauft
letztendlich weißt du nicht was da drin
ist ist es jetzt ein bier oder ist das
jetzt ein schnaps oder ist es vielleicht
ein windschutz
ist eine kühlflüssigkeit die er halt
eigentlich war nicht schön konsum
ausgelegt ist weil es gibt ja zum
beispiel auch cannabinoide das sind
künstlich hergestellte
quasi künstlich hergestellt und ist thc
ähnlich aber das ist zum beispiel was
was sehr viel eher psychosen auslöst als
ich sag mal nicht hoch potenzial hoch
potenziert es cannabis und eben es gibt
auch cannabis das gestreckt ist das zum
beispiel mit haarspray besprüht wurde
damit das schwerer ist und dann teurer
verkaufen werden kann und das sind
sachen die auch sehr schnell psychosen
auslösen können ich will ja gar nicht
jetzt sagen kann der business new das
aus aber ich glaube wenn das legale
möglichkeiten gäbe kann er bis zu
beziehen dann könnte man zum einen sagen
will ich jetzt gerade starkes oder
schwaches cannabis und man kann vor
allem sicher sein dass es auch eine
saubere qualität ist die dann
hoffentlich auch ja weniger leute dazu
oder weniger leuten an psychosen
anhängt quasi
ja florian also ist es wirklich eine
spannende debatte ich bin auch sehr
gespannt wie sie weitergeht ich danke
dir jedenfalls dass du so offen war es
das mal aus deinem leben erzählt hast
und erzählt hast welche konsequenzen das
haben kann und vielleicht in zukunft
nicht mehr haben muss ja herzlichen dank
florian schöne grüße nach würzburg
vielen dank nochmal für die einladung
und schönen tag
[Musik]
so nach diesem herzerfrischenden
schwerpunkt der sich mal nicht mit vier
juristischer theorie beschäftigt sondern
mit sehr viel praxis bleiben wir bei
einem ich weiß nicht ob ich praktischen
thema sagen soll lebens noch ein thema
auf jeden fall ist es total wert corinna
du hast uns einen termin mitgebracht in
unserer wunderschönen kategorie was
kommt ich glaube es geht nämlich am
morgigen donnerstag los bezeichnen am
mittwoch den 20 10 auf und ich muss
sagen es ist ein termin aus der
kategorie womit die justiz sich so
rumschlagen muss ja er ist es wirklich
ganz es geht um den drachen lord erkläre
ich gleich muss morgen erscheint am
donnerstag vor dem amtsgericht neustadt
an der aisch
die sind so aufgeregt dass sie jetzt die
räumlichkeiten und personellen
kapazitäten des
oberlandesgerichts nürnberg in anspruch
nehmen also richter des amtsgerichts
werden das ist vielleicht sogar erstmals
am oberlandesgericht
recht sprechen über den drachen los und
dass er jetzt endlich mal france und so
denkt leider total von total fight muss
man nicht sagen wirklich total falsch
er ist ein typ der ein youtube mit dem
namen rainer w punkt
ist landesweit bekannt und bei vielen
vielen für youtube nutzern die sich
seine seinen kanal anschauen seine
videos anschauen und wirklich große lust
verspüren sich über den herzumachen ihn
zu beflügeln und ja zu mobben muss man
sagen also das ist ein zustand der
inzwischen übrigens seit mehreren jahren
schon anhält constantin also und ein
wert der vorgänger der gründer dieses
großartigen podcast mit dem habe ich
schon im
jahr 2018 ich glaube es war august oder
april
jedenfalls in folge 37 haben wir uns
schon über den drachen lord
unterhalten weil wir so durchgeknallt
von sieht das kann da kann man mal
wieder rein hören also dieser gegend
lebt ja am ende das heißt gar nicht mehr
davon dass der bestimmte inhalte erzähle
ich glaube es ging bei dem eigentlich
früher mal um gaming und so was also ist
so ein typischer nerdy anmutender typ
irgendwie der da im schlabber t shirt
umsonst genau gaming und heavy metal der
sagt auch immer irgendwas ganz lustiges
zum ich hab da mal reingehört irgendwie
sowas wie medal leute
und so begrüßte die leute immer aber
darum geht es eigentlich gar nicht mehr
sondern mittlerweile geht es irgendwie
darum dass er seine zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer hated und sie hätten ihn und
alle hätten sich gegenseitig richtig ist
ein riesiges pribil festmachen sichtlich
und solange das noch im netz ist nur im
netz stattfindet ist das ja schlimm
genug ja aber das hat sich schon in die
reale welt
transferiert es geht auch das geht schon
eben seit jahren wie gesagt schon im
jahr 2018 war es ja so dass das ganze in
die reale welt übergeschwappt ist dass
leute dahin pilgerten und zwar nicht nur
zwei oder drei sondern wirklich hunderte
wenn nicht gar tausende also wir
sprachen damals um über eine versammlung
von 5000 leuten die dieses dorf belagern
wie gesagt sind alle genervt der
bürgermeister weiß kaum noch zu helfen
macht aber das hat er ja auch so ein
bisschen selbst herausgefordert
und der bürger maxlrainer der gesagt hat
dann kommt auch hier bei mir vorbei wenn
nämlich hier nur im netz helfen wollte
und hat seine komplette adresse genannt
ja unter dem hat er den salat traut euch
kommt zu mir ich prügel die scheiße aus
euch raus das war ein zitat jetzt denn
sonst was man würde es ja nie so
sprechen wäre dann liefen sie alle auf
in alt schaumberg einem dorf mit nicht
mal 50 einwohner fürchten nicht so und
jetzt weiß natürlich das amtsgericht und
sich nicht anders zu helfen die
befürchten natürlich auch schlimmes
letztlich ist es total trivial worum es
geht jetzt hier vor dem amtsgericht
neustadt
in dem ich nur um nur ne also um
beleidigung weil im zuge einer dieser
zusammentreffen
der rheiner wie punkt einen polizisten
angepöbelt haben soll deswegen eben die
beleidigung und außerdem solle eine von
diesen händlern verletzt haben mit einer
taschenlampe soll auf ihn eingeprügelt
haben und deswegen steht auch noch
gefährliche körperverletzung im raum das
sind also die strafrechtlichen vorwürfe
die ihm da gemacht werden normalerweise
total winzige hinter eines banales
strafverfahren was eben vom amtsgericht
stattfinden da sitzt normalerweise kein
mensch hinten drin und im zweifel gibt
es ein paar sozialstunden und und böse
mahnende worte und dann geht man wieder
nach hause so jetzt in nürnberg genau
deswegen findet jetzt die
hauptverhandlung im sitzungssaal
006 stadt sollte man vielleicht
eigentlich gar nicht so öffentlich sagen
geht da nicht hingehen kind da gibt es
nicht zu sehen gehen sie weiter bitte
nicht nachmachen lieber die mal zum
bundesverfassungsgericht reisen ja das
ist recht viel aufregender wir haben wir
viel viel mehr empfehlen gut aber
nichtsdestotrotz falls das jetzt wieder
die boulevardzeitung
bevölkert dieses thema oder falls
vielleicht auch sogar eine fazit man
bricht erscheinen wollte wissen sie
wissen worum es geht das wird also jetzt
in den nächsten ein zwei wochen dort
stattfinden dann wird es ein urteil
geben und die sache wird
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht vorbei sein
[Musik]
du hast noch ein nachtrag dabei genau
nämlich zum bundesgerichtshof das hatten
wir glaube ich vor zwei wochen erzählt
beim bgh ging es um den einsturz des
kölner stadtarchivs also wir haben das
detaillierter gemacht in der folge 180
da hatte ich so ein bisschen davon
erzählt wie es damals war das sei ja
schon 2009 das sind köln das stadtarchiv
eingestürzt ist das war verursacht
wurden durch die u bahn baustelle in der
nähe und da war quasi eine komplette
grube vollgelaufen mit wasser und
schlamm und allem was da eben so rum lag
und eine wand die ganz offensichtlich
falsch errichtet worden war ist dann
zusammengebrochen und dann sind alle
gebäude drumrum unterspült worden und
das gesamte stadtarchiv ist irgendwie
eingestürzt damals zwei menschen
gestorben riesiger kultureller schaden
wollen natürlich das gesamte der gesamte
inhalt des kölner stadtarchivs auch in
dieser baugrube
versuchten ist sozusagen und das
landgericht köln hatte aber zwei der
verantwortlichen bauleiter
freigesprochen sie hätten zwar irgendwie
schon was falsch gemacht also nicht
hinreichend dokumentiert und auch
diverse baumängel die da irgendwie
aufgefallen waren nicht hinreichend
aufgeschrieben und eben vor allem auch
nicht weitergegeben quasi an die
abteilung die nach ihnen dran war mit
dem weiterbau aber so das lg köln damals
hat das hätte auch nicht verhindert dass
das stadtarchiv eingestürzt ist und
damit auch der tod der beiden menschen
sozusagen zustande kam wenn sie alles
richtig gemacht hätten und da hat jetzt
der bgh gesagt na
ja also der bgh hat gesagt so einfach
ist es nicht jetzt muss eine andere
strafkammer beim lg köln komplett neu
entscheiden und zwar nicht erst ansetzen
bei der kausalität also wo ja quasi das
lg gesagt hatte da fliegt raus sondern
der bgh hat gesagt die kammer hätte
schon wichtige umstände nicht
berücksichtigt bei der bestimmung der
sorgfaltspflichten der beiden
verantwortlichen bauleiter also es war
halt zu mehreren zwischenfällen auf der
baustelle gekommen das war auch klar und
das war auch dem lg klar das steht auch
im urteil und es steht auch im urteil
dass es keine abstimmung gab es zwischen
diesen einzelnen abteilungen quasi die
die einzelnen bauabschnitte gemacht
haben in dieser u bahn und da sagt der
bgh das ist halt so eklatant gewesen
dass es so eine abstimmung nicht gab und
auch gar nicht geben sollte
nachdem war sie ablaufplan und das trotz
allem obwohl da so viel schiefgegangen
ist keiner mal irgendwie gesagt hat dass
gucken wir uns hier mal detaillierte an
dass man da sagen muss dass die
kompletten sorgfaltspflichten sich
nochmal neu anschauen muss das heißt
alles zurück als er gut also auch das
wird uns noch weiter beschäftigen
dann können wir jetzt zum gerechten
urteil immer und das kommt in dieser
woche vom sozialgericht darmstadt und
wir wissen jetzt dass zumindest nach
ansicht des sozialgerichts darmstadt
jürgen klopp kein künstler ist ja berge
tagung für opel macht genau wer hätte
das gedacht also wir erinnern uns alle
an diese wirklich sehr sehr bekannten
und breit ausgerollten werbekampagnen in
den jahren 22 15 und da kam es jetzt zu
einer sehr lustigen konstellation auch
das wieder aus der kategorie womit die
justiz sich alles rumschlagen muss
nämlich die deutsche rentenversicherung
hat von opel verlangt dass opel
sozialabgaben nach zeit und zwar in
sechsstelliger höhe weil eben opel
damals in diesen jahren werbung gemacht
hatte mit schauspielern mit models und
eben mit jürgen klopp an dieser stelle
muss man leider den zwei leuten die
nicht wissen wer jürgen klopp ist sagen
wir jeder klopp ist seit ich für völlig
ausgeschlossen kloppo ist er ist der
ehemalige trainer von bvb jeder mensch
kennt jugendclub oder also ich bin jetzt
echt kein fußballfan aber jeder kennt
auch ihren club leute nur der
vollständigkeit halber jetzt ist er in
england mir fällt gerade nicht ein wo
siehst du jetzt wird's peinlich corinna
das haben lieber holen was
also schnell zum fall zurück genau
kommen wir schnell zurück zu den
juristischen themen es ging um die
künstlersozialabgabe die müssen
unternehmen zahlen wenn sie
künstlerinnen und künstler beschäftigen
und so wird dann am ende quasi die rente
und die kranken und die
pflegeversicherung für künstler und
publizisten bezahlt also in teilen das
natürlich alles ein riesiges
kompliziertes system aber jedenfalls
lange rede kurzer sinn auch wenn man als
unternehmen werbung macht mit der hilfe
von künstlerinnen und künstlern egal ob
die jetzt angestellt sind oder man die
als freie mitarbeiter engagiert dann
muss man eben eine künstlersozialabgabe
zahlen und das hat ja nun eben auch opel
jahre lang und sehr erfolgreich ach
diese sozial abgabe orientiert sich
natürlich auch an den garagen und
deswegen hat die deutsche
rentenversicherung gesagt so dafür für
die wahrscheinlich sehr sehr hohe gage
für jürgen klopp hätten wir doch jetzt
gerne für den die künstler sozial eine
sozial abgabe für die jahre 215 und
deswegen musste das sozialgericht in
darmstadt jetzt darüber entscheiden ob
kloppo ein künstler im sinne des
künstlersozialversicherungsgesetz assist
und die haben tatsächlich gesagt nein
nein wer hätte das gedacht also im ernst
die haben denn mit aktiven sportlern
verglichen wo der bgh schon entschieden
hat dass die ihre bekanntheit zu
werbezwecken nutzen und eben nicht
deshalb künstler sind und das sg
darmstadt sagte genauso wie ein sportler
ist auch ein trainer zu behandeln und
der macht er diesen job als testimonial
eben gerade nicht als künstler sondern
er macht ihn weil er so berühmt geworden
ist mit seinem hauptjob trainer ja dass
der der erzählt ja nur zusätzliche
einnahmen und abzustellen ist eben auf
den hauptjob der ja quasi diesem
testimonial job erst möglich gemacht
also die werbetätigkeit ist eine achtung
super juristen wort an next tätigkeit im
hauptjob als trainer kloppo ist kein
künstler und ich fand das sehr sehr
schön das sg darmstadt hat sogar in die
überschrift geschrieben irgendwie
fußballtrainer sind keine künstler
jedenfalls nicht außerhalb ist ja sehr
sehr schön da freut man sich auch als
sozial gerecht wenn man so was schönes
spannendes man machen kann ja genau
deswegen haben wir es auch an den
schluss gesetzt dieses podcast weil man
sich als sozial gerecht freut dass man
das so spannend das machen das ist ein
gerechtes
weil es vor allen dingen schönen
sachverhalt waren punkten es jetzt mal
ganz deutlich zu sagen ja und weil wir
uns ja auch freuen wenn wir uns und euch
mit so schön bunt ja weil letztendlich
also gerecht weil du bist mir jetzt
ehrlich gesagt wurscht ob opel noch zum
die deutsche versicherung muss ich ja
doch auch schön dann haben die künstler
mehr also wir kommen total vom thema
habe die deutsche rentenversicherung
kriegt kein geld opel muss keine
künstlersozialabgabe für jürgen klopp
zahlen meint er allenfalls auf dem platz
endgültig ein ballkünstler gut dann sind
wir jetzt tatsächlich am ende mit
unserem latein bedanken uns wahnsinnig
für die aufmerksamkeit auch ich bedanke
mich bei dir
wir bitten natürlich wahnsinnig um
feedback ich sag's gerne noch mal ein
spruch podcast faz.de oder auch alle
anderen gängigen kanäle auf unserer
webseite kann man gerne nachricht
hinterlassen oder auch sternchen im weiß
lila apple podcast gedöns app dings und
auch in andere podcast gedöns app ging's
nicht nur von apps kann man da er aber
kann man da auch nachrichten
hinterlassen also wäre es dass
nachrichten sondern bewertung hinter was
oder geht das nicht nur beim plan ich
hab auch ne richtig also mir hat das
immerhin darf uns überall bewertungen
hinterlassen ich weiß nur dann nicht so
glauben wenn du nicht so genau wie wir
dann davon erfahren wenn wir noch nicht
wissen aber das kann gut das fragen wir
die techniker die wissen ja gut also
dann wünschen noch einen schönen rest
woche bis dann tschüss otto
[Musik]